[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de leur formation avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur leur
terrain voici tout de suite les grands
titres de l'actualité de ce lundi 14
décembre outre-atlantique place au vote
celui du collège électoral pour élire
officiellement celui qui sera le
prochain président américain
une formalité en théorie car les 538
grands électeurs se prononcent dans un
contexte tendu
donald trump ne reconnaît toujours pas
sa défaite joe biden préval lui prévoit
lui de prononcer un discours depuis sa
ville de wilmington pour célébrer la
confirmation de sa victoire
côté vaccination la campagne a débuté
une soignante new yorkaise et la
première vacciner contre le coc vide en
france fin du confinement et passage au
couvre-feu entre 20h et 6h à partir de
demain
plus besoin d'attestation journée deux
villes
le havre et charleville mézières donne
le coup d'envoi aujourd'hui d'une
campagne de dépistage massif au co vide
avec pour ambition de tester une partie
importante de la population à la veille
des fêtes
alors que le nombre de contaminations ne
baisse plus depuis plusieurs jours déjà
des progrès mais toujours des
divergences notamment sur la pêche les
négociations sur le bret site se
poursuit finalement elle devait prendre
fin hier cette fois ci aucune date
butoir n'a été fixée pour berlin la
négociation doit se poursuivre tant
qu'un accord est possible le 1er janvier
le divorce entre le royaume uni et
l'union européenne sera effectif avec ou
sans accord commercial
[Musique]
les états unis
où les 538 grands électeurs doivent donc
formaliser ce lundi la victoire de jo
baydan à la présidentielle de novembre
mais cette année leur vote revêt une
importance toute particulière face au
refus obstiné de donald trump de
reconnaître sa défaite
alors le vote du collège électoral petit
nous réserver encore des surprises
éléments de réponse avec thomas bonnet
ils sont 5 138 et ils ont une
responsabilité immense celle de désigner
le futur président des états unis
les grands électeurs votent ce lundi et
selon les projections des médias
américains 306 d'entre eux devraient
choisir joe biden attestant des
résultats de l'élection présidentielle
dans les différents états américains
d'habitude c'est une formalité mais
cette année avec les accusations du camp
républicain dénonçant une fraude lors de
l'élection le déroulement du vote va
être surveillé avec attention
donald trump qui n'a toujours pas
concédé sa défaite à échanger avec des
journalistes à ce sujet c'était à la fin
du mois de novembre
si le collège des grands électeurs
votent pour joe biden le 14 décembre
concède aurez-vous l'élection ce sera
très difficile à admettre car nous
savons qu'il ya eu une fraude massive
quant à savoir si je peux ou non faire
avancer cette machine est rapidement
parce que le temps ne joue pas en notre
faveur
tout le reste est de notre côté les
faits sont de notre côté il s'agit d'une
fraude massive
monsieur juste pour être clair si le
collège des grands électeurs votent pour
joe biden allez vous concédez s'ils le
font ils ferait une erreur car cette
élection était une imposture pour que
vous compreniez bien cette élection
était une imposture
la question est donc de savoir si ces
accusations de fraude ont relayé par le
locataire de la maison blanche peuvent
trouver un écho parmi les grands
électeurs républicains et s'il pourrait
être tenté de ne pas suivre les
résultats annoncés dans certains états
selon la plupart des analystes cités
dans les médias américains cela est très
improbable
déjà parce que dans une trentaine
d'états la loi oblige les grands
électeurs à suivre le vote populaire
d'autre part car les trahisons sont
rarissimes dans l'histoire un chiffre
pour en témoigner
sur les 23 milles
507 vote des grands électeurs lors des
58 élection présidentielle seuls 90
votants ont changé leur vote
ce fut notamment le cas en 2000 lorsque
la démocrate barbara l'aide simons
s'étaient abstenus les suppositions vont
bon train aux états unis certains
estimant que donald trump et ses équipes
agissent en coulisses pour influencer
tel ou tel grand électeur en 2016
un appel à la révolte des opposants à
donald trump n'avaient rien donné
la victoire du milliardaire avait été
confirmée par le collège électoral
une chose est sûre pour inverser la
tendance et l'issue du scrutin donald
trump aurait besoin cette année d'une
quarantaine de revirement de la part de
grands électeurs pour connaître l'issue
il faudra peut être patienter jusqu'au 6
janvier c'est le jour où le congrès doit
annoncer officiellement le nom du
vainqueur
et si donald trump est vaincu le tram
puisse me semble lui bien vivant on
l'aura compris avec ce sujet alors le
président peut-il continuer à exercer
son influence sur le parti républicain
le travaillisme est il un vrai danger
pour le futur président biden est une
force politique avec laquelle il devra
composer
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
antoinette laurin vice présidente à des
républicaines france bonsoir en
toilettes laura merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés pour débattre théo lobry
animateurs du groupe bernie sanders
france bonsoir théo lobry merci d'être
avec nous vous aussi à leur première
question a tout d'abord sur ce processus
électoral qui suit son cours a toujours
aux états unis les grands électeurs sont
appelés aux urnes
à leur tour ils se réunissent et par mg
en état par état toute la journée
aujourd'hui donc pour officialiser la
victoire de joe biden ils vont le
désigner comme prévu aucun doute
là-dessus théo lobry oui a priori aucun
doute déjà plusieurs états ont désigné
enfin les grands électeurs ont déjà
parlé dans plusieurs états notamment la
pennsylvanie ou encore la géorgie et si
bien joe biden qui a remporté les grands
électeurs de ces états donc a priori il
n'y aura aucune surprise
ce qui est tout à fait normal alors sur
les réseaux sociaux et tout
particulièrement twitter donald trump
lui digère toujours aussi mal sa défaite
il continue de dénoncer l et fraude
toujours sans savoir fournir de vraies
preuves un finalement regarder ses
derniers tweets c'était hier les états
clés qui ont trouvé une fraude massive
ce qui est le cas pour tous ne peuvent
pas certifié légalement ces votes comme
complet est correct sans commettre un
crime sévèrement punissable tout le
monde sait que les morts les mineurs les
immigrés clandestins
les fausses signatures les prisonniers
et bien d'autres ont voté illégalement
en outre les défaillances de la machine
un autre mot pour fraude
la récolte des bulletins de vote les
électeurs non résidents les faux
bulletins de vote
le bourrage des urnes les votes pour
l'argent la brutalité des observateurs
du scrutin républicain et parfois même
plus de votes que les votants a pris
place à détroit philadelphie
milwaukee atlanta pittsburgh et ailleurs
dans tous les états clés il ya beaucoup
plus de voix que nécessaire pour gagner
l'état et l'élection elle-même
par conséquent les votes ne peuvent être
certifié cette élection est contestée
qu'antoinette lorrain ces accusations de
fraude on parle depuis le début en
quasiment depuis le 3 novembre donal
trump ça fait vraiment est courant chez
les militants républicains
beaucoup y croient finalement dans votre
camp bien tir mais je veux aussi raconté
attention de ceux qui sont en ce qu'on
appelle les rails nos rubriques aînée
mandy en fait dans les législatures des
de chaque état on voit une complicité
des républicains qui ont choisi le voit
quand il a fallu d'entente est en fait
président 30 représente nouveau parti il
ya des rumeurs de ce qui s'appelle ce
nouveau parti mais deux appartements
il faut vraiment que vous
téléspectateurs comprendre que le le
minstre immédiat de médias qu on voit
cnn msmb signifie si abc il ya une
complicité affrontement très forte
contre président trempe on avoue
aujourd'hui que si elle n était attaquée
en justice par le supplieront deux
secrétaires des fentes cache pas tel
aujourd'hui pour 50 millions de dollars
c'est à dire qu' il s'agit d'une grande
croissance de diffamation contre des
gens qui se tuent en train et il faut
aussi prendre attiré l'attention du
téléspectateur de la fête que les
démocrates
ils demandent des violentes contre les
supporteurs le train est par exemple
avec la radio corps qu'elle commence à
peine à michigan state jardiner l'été
elle a publié une vidéo sur facebook en
appelons tous les supporters de 3 et
elle a menacé avec la violence d'une
façon assez importante elle
tekori j'ai quand même un carton
dictature mais il faut pardonnez moi
parce que là vous faites allusion à
plusieurs choses si j'ai bien compris il
ya le côté que vous dénoncez partisans
des médias américains et après voilà
d'autres fêtes de violence entre les
supporters parce que cette campagne a
été a été rude
théo lobry est ce que justement vous
l'admettrez vous parce que pour avoir eu
la chance de couvrir les élections aux
états unis on va pas se mentir ils ne
sont démentes pas eux mêmes c'est vrai
que les médias américains étaient pro by
day excepté évidemment fox news comme
chacun sait mais c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
une campagne menée par les médias
américains en faveur en tout cas contre
donald trump ça vous l'admettrez du côté
des démocrates
oui je crois que toute façon pour ce qui
est de cnn
nsn bissy et c'est effectivement sont
démocrates sont ce sont des médias
pardon de la côte est des états unis
plutôt démocrate mais on va dire la
ligne centriste c'est à dire que
démocrate version joe biden ou
républicain version mitt romney
admettant donc ça on peut tout à fait
l'admettre après il faut il faut pas
oublier que fox news a une importance
toute particulière durant ces quatre
dernières années
qu'aujourd'hui les réseaux sociaux sont
absolument saturé par la parole des
ultra conservateurs et d'être en piste
par exemple
et en plus de ça le fait est que cnn et
tous les médias qu'on pourrait qualifier
de démocrates ont participé aussi à
servent à devenir donald trump à la
présidence des etats unis puisque en
permanence en fonction de ses phrases
qui etc
il parle de lui alors ils sont coincés
parce qu'ils sont obligés de parler de
lui mais ça lui fait aussi de la pub
c'est de l'argent qui n'est pas dépensé
dans la campagne pour des spots
télévision puisque donald trump et à la
télé tous les soirs donc oui c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut admettre en
effet mais je ne suis pas sûr
aujourd'hui que
cnn où ces médias qu'on a cité juste
avant et une influence énorme les états
unis sont sont assez fracturé les
républicains ne regarde pas cnn les
démocrates ne regarde pas foxes
antoinette laurent on parlait de ces
faux de rodin que dénonce donald trump
qui font écho chez les militants vous
parliez de ces médias américains mais
enfin tout de même il y a tout
simplement les recours judiciaires et
pour l'instant ça n'a rien donné pour le
président trump à ce qu'il en a encore
quelques uns ou ça y est c'est trop tard
d'abord je souhaite abréger les points
de votre de mon collègue qui en fait
parmi les morts continue il a démontré
avec redresser les autres journalistes
qui sont des partis pris des lladounes
de deux poids deux mesures
en fait quand nous ils vont te demande
pas en ce moment
berne yooz met et verts - l'américain
news la patineuse n'est plus considérée
comme pertinente dans le journalisme
sans via des ce qui intéressant
aujourd'hui pour moi c'est la sortie des
puits sur les bases de données de
calibration calligrammes c'est une jolie
g vous connaissez comme moi taxe mais
c'est géré par des roustes nationale
monsieur kebous nationaliste ce qui est
intéressant c'est tous les partis
communistes supporter d'un autre pays
occidentaux il ya une règle 95 millions
des partis communistes enregistrées dans
des bases de données que l'on a
découverte et ils ont promis au parti
communiste chinois de garder le secret
du parti de être fidèle de travailler
dur et de 7,1 pour le communisme est en
fait on trouve dans cette déco
découverte aujourd'hui que fire
astrazeneca ceux qui produisent des
vaccins il ya 123 fidèle à ce parti
communiste pendant un petit moment il
faut vraiment poser des questions
surtout que les médias nous dit parce
que en fait c'est pas du tout ce qu'on
comprend deux dans des réalités
en tout cas à propos de ce vaccin
antoine et clorinde donald trump se
défend lui-même il affirmé hier sur
foxnews d'ailleurs que les états unis
auraient mis cinq ans à développer un
vaccin contre le corps un avis du ru
virus il n'avait pas été président théo
lobry est-ce que vous lui concédé au
moins cela à donald trump c'est vrai
qu'il avait été très critiquée en
annonçant en septembre qu'un vaccin les
survenir certainement avant novembre et
finalement ça a été le cas quel est
aujourd'hui votre réaction
alors dans un premier temps je voulais
simplement réagir à ce que ce qu'a dit
la personne qui débat avec moi ce soir
on est encore dans une dans une
démonstration un exemple de toute cette
sphère conspirationnistes complotistes
qui tient les partisans donald trump
enfin du moins une partie des partisans
de donald trump je l'aimé pas tous dans
ce même sac et vous voyez bien voir
enfin j'espère que les téléspectateurs
se rendre compte à quel point c'est tiré
par les cheveux
le parti communiste chinois qui aurait
plus ou moins une ingérence auprès de
pfizer qui une entreprise privée
américaine qui est sous l'autorité du de
des autorités sanitaires américaines
enfin on marche complètement sur la tête
et le pire dans tout ça c'est
qu'effectivement comme vous l'avez
rappelé c'est sous la présidence de
donald trump que ce vaccin est apparu et
a été diffusé dans le monde
c'est une prouesse on espère qu'avec le
temps les résultats seront positifs pour
ce vaccin qu'il n'y aura pas de souci
et si là où on peut reconnaître à donald
trump mais c'est plutôt aux états unis
de façon générale un point positif c'est
l'argent qui a investi par les
américains dans la recherche et c'est
bien aussi un petit problème qu'on a
nous en europe et particulièrement en
france où
on voit effectivement tous les
chercheurs qui partent aux états unis
parce que les entreprises ont plus
d'argent les autorités les autorités
soutiennent bien plus la recherche en
france
donc est ce que c'est un point positif
pour donald trump en tout cas ça aurait
été fait pendant son mandat donc
effectivement on peut lui on peut lui
donner le crédit d'avoir soutenu soutenu
cette recherche par le biais de millions
et 2 milliards de dollars je voudrais
qu'on termine pas par ces chiffres un +
18% entre les deux élections donald
trump est passé de 62 à 74 millions de
voir en quatre ans il a donc renforcé sa
base
n'est ce pas un peu dangereux tout de
même pour joe biden ce genre de chiffres
à roanne est lorrain vous vous espérez
que votre poulain se représente en 2024
est-ce qu'il a un boulevard avec ces
chiffres où il en fera un autre jour
selon vous ce sera le mot de la fin
non je crois que 2004 c'est maintenant
ou jamais en fait on en compte de l'âge
de parler d'entente et on demande qu'on
de l'âge de présidente à edel en fait
tous les deux ils sont assez à l'aller
ni de pouvoir présider un pays comme les
etats-unis dans notre pays surtout un
tout bon état de santé mentale et
physique jogging et démontre des signes
de déclin cognitif mentale et physique
mais par rapport 2007 au niveau de vote
populaire dans notre championnat
il a gagné 4 20 et 4 21 millions de
votes pas 74
en fait c'est dommage parce que votre
monsieur clermont ferrand en fait vous
savez que par des miracles il a volé
pour les lavaur de serre note qui était
tout haut
le vrai candidat démocrate et donnez moi
parce que pour les téléspectateurs parce
que c'est vrai que tout voilà on a
million de votes c'est par rapport
décennies town et the world les avocates
qui sont entraîne de l'embauché des
scientifiques au port antique qui étudie
les bases de données des vôtres dans ce
système de dominion est en fait c'est
tout maintenant que jamais les
importants d'europe story notre système
électoral et de donner des priorités est
de vraiment illuminé tous deux
possibilités de deux de tricher par paul
ii en droit des étrangers
on peut dire que en fait les chinois à
la donne est en train de s'éloigner en
tout cas c'était pour le mot de la fin
je vous demande et voilà si vous pensiez
que de n'être pas l'être vous espériez
en tout cas qu'il se représente en 2024
vous pensez que c'est fini nous amener
de l'orage suis désolé on est à la fin
de cette ce débat effectivement et je ne
cache pas que c'est un petit peu
compliqué parce que ce sont des
allégations qu'on ne peut pas vérifier
bien évidemment ici sur ce plateau
voilà donc vous comprendrez que c'est un
petit peu compliqué effectivement on a
entendu en tout cas votre message on
vous allez s'est déroulé tout ça mais
c'est vrai que ce sont des allégations
qu'on a du mal à vérifier la bonne et
moi président et dubaï
ce n'est pas encore sûr il faut encore
attendre jusqu'au 20 janvier même si le
6 janvier par la constitution américaine
donne jusqu'à 22 janvier pour déterminer
qui est le président et doux et je pense
que cette bataille il ya 91 américain
millions d'américains qui sont vraiment
en colère de cette fraude massive dans
notre système électoral
on verra des conséquences mais pendant
ce temps il faut pas laisser l'espoir
d'accord très bien très bien deux cas
chacun à exprimer son point de vue merci
antoinette laurent merci également à
théo lobry d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france et aux états unis
un toujours ce coup d'envoi ce lundi de
la campagne de vaccination contre le coc
vide 19
les premiers lots de vaccins father
biotech sont arrivés dans les centres de
vaccination feather annoncé qu'une
vingtaine d'avions seront mobilisés
chaque jour pour transporter au moins
trois millions de doses d'ici mercredi
objectif vacciner 20 millions
d'américains avant la fin de l'année 100
millions avant la fin du mois de mars
prochain
c'est une soignante new yorkaise qui à
la première personne vaccinée contre le
pot vide aux états unis côté je veux
donner confiance au public dont
l'innocuité du vaccin
nous sommes en pleine pandémie et nous
devons donc tous faire notre part pour y
mettre fin et ne pas abandonner si vite
nous voyons la lumière au bout du tunnel
mais nous devons continuer à porter nos
masques à pratiquer la distanciation
sociale et pour en parler nous sommes en
direct depuis houston avec dave perkins
analyse politique et supporters de
donald trump c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur
[Musique]
on soit des vins perkins merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france les
premières vaccinations donc c'était
aujourd'hui new yorkaise une une fierté
pour vous non pas du tout je pense que
le processus a été bien trop rapide
qu'on a trop insisté sur l'importance du
vaccin et jeu j'ai bien peur que ce
vaccin rentrer dans des plans futurs du
gouvernement à différents niveaux pour
développer un contrôle bien plus
important sur les dépassements et les
achats de la population qui tuent leurs
et un jeu de passes soins de santé
ferait la différence entre d'exclusion
de première classe et de se rendre place
c'est très préoccupant pour corps pour
moi et je pense que la santé ne justifie
croit cela et j'en suis certain une fois
que le gouvernement a le contrôle à ce
point alors on ne peut plus repartir en
arrière je suis très inquiet david
perkins porte bien pour qu'on comprenne
c'est à dire il y aura ceux qui ont les
moyens de se faire vacciner et les
autres on a on n'est pas sûr de
comprendre cette idée de votre justement
votre inquiétude entre les citoyens de
seconde zone et les autres si on ne
passe pas de santé disant qu'on a été
vaccinées alors on devient un trait aux
premières classes on peut se déplacer
même un niveau interne à turin aulas et
les restrictions ne s'appliquent pas à
vous à l'avenir car vous avez ce
transport
si on ne se fait pas vacciner alors le
gouvernement peut imposer des
restrictions
aujourd'hui comme à l'avenir et il leur
suffira que nos petits airs il ya une
augmentation du nombre des
contaminations et donc les personnes son
passeport ne peuvent plus faire ceci ou
cela
et donc très bientôt il y aura une
campagne afin de pousser les gens qui
n'ont pas été vaccinés à le faire le
vaccin deviendra obligatoire
est ce qu'ils ne se feront pas vacciner
face à des conséquences très graves dont
des restrictions à leur vie tout est
très malin jusqu'à la pointe de l'or à
la venue l'idée que s'il n'a pas été
vaccinés contre une maladie qui tue très
très peu de gens plein de gens que la
côte
l'idée donc fait vacciner vaccin pour
être obligatoire et qu'il pourrait y
avoir des conséquences légales en cas de
refus c'est très préoccupant pour moi
vous c'est en quelque sorte se rendre la
vaccination obligatoire qui vous pose
problème c'est un problème tout
simplement de liberté individuelle la
liberté publique qui se pose aujourd'hui
clairement c'est avec toi c'est vraiment
une situation très difficile
la production de ce vaccin utilise je
crois en les morceaux devait apporter et
je pense que pour cette raison de larges
parties ont des américains décideront
mais pour des raisons au 2 juin de ne
pas utiliser ce vaccin caf du nord a été
produit avec le morceau qui ont des
besoins portée de fonds de protection
religieuse encore je suis désolé
effectivement c'est compliqué pour nous
de vérifier ce genre d'allégations parce
qu'évidemment la plupart des personnes
et d'ailleurs y compris les
scientifiques en france non non pas eu d
les communiqués ces fameuses études
scientifiques qui sont publiés dans les
revues on ne les a pas eu donc c'est
vrai que c'est très compliqué de
vérifier ce genre d'information une
chose est sûre c'est que donald trump
que vous supportez que vous soutenez lui
voilà se targue d'avoir mis en place ce
vaccin sans lui il le dit il n'y aurait
pas eu de vaccins avant cinq ans vous
partagez ce diagnostic du président
sortant je pense que donald trump ou
quoi faire cette colle donc je ne suis
pas d'accord avec lui sur l'industrie
tels que je ne soutiens pas aux rideaux
politique central se retrouver devant ma
porte et me disais que lui dirait
monsieur le président fait ce que j'ai
fait je ne me ferai pas vacciner pour
une série de raisons et en appartement
en aucune mais il y en a d'autres
par exemple ces théories du concours que
vous avez entendu
et moi je n'ai pas effectivement la
formation pour corps est retrouvé ou
l'invalider certaines personnes disent
que ce vaccin permettrait de deux de
stériliser les gens c'est à dire de les
empêcher de faire des enfants
et afin de réduire la population niveau
plan le caire il ya d'autres théories du
complot qui si par exemple que il
s'agirait d'un pu traiter des maladies à
l'avenir non car cela changerait les
corps il ya beaucoup de questions et je
ne veux pas croire en nos réponses qu'on
propose les je vais prendre le temps de
faire des recherches d'être certain que
le faire vacciner n'irait pas à
l'encontre de ma conscience pour le
moment je ne suis pas assez informés
pour prendre cette décision pour décider
de me faire voir ou encore beaucoup de
questions sur ce vaccin et vous exprimer
certainement le doute de plusieurs de
vos concitoyens en attendant donc des
des études peu fiable c'est en tout cas
ce que vous nous dites dave perkins
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france pour vu de l'extérieur ce
soir et la russie elle aussi a déjà
commencé avec signer une partie de sa
population
après moscou et ses alentours qui ont
débuté les injections le 5 décembre
c'est au tour d'autres grandes régions
du pays de recevoir le vaccin spoutnik v
les villes de penza belgorod ou
kamchatka ont reçu le précieux sésame
depuis septembre plus deux cent mille
personnes ont déjà été vaccinées dans le
cadre d'une campagne de masse en russie
est resté avec nous dans quelques
instants nous aborderons la crise
sanitaire en france avec la fin du
confinement et de passage se marier au
couvre feu deux villes le havre et
charleville mézières donne le coup
d'envoi aujourd'hui à d'une campagne de
dépistage massif et nous parlerons du
bric site ou européens et britanniques
poursuivent les négociations à marche
forcée
m
[Musique]
comment choisissez-vous un film un
projet un scénario un réalisateur avant
de choisir on ait choisi ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sentiments des idées des émotions
vous vous êtes vraiment dans le cinéma
de créateurs d'initiateur je crois que
le cinéma c'est comme la peinture c'est
comme le la littérature ça reste un art
déco maintenant c'est l'industrie qui
gagne mais du coup peut-être qu est-ce
qui va rester c'est que les films qui
seront de plus en plus fait pour le
cinéma et pas sur les grands réseaux
resteront des objets artistiques godard
qui disait cette chose si forte
quand on regarde la télévision en baisse
les yeux quand on va au cinéma enlève
les yeux de teddy
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde même si on
n'est pas en appartement on est énervé
grenelle sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
loin de paris mais toujours loin de ceux
qui les dirigent
moi j'en ai marre qu'on y passe un tour
de tracteur et cnooc vivre en campagne
il faut savoir c'est qu'une vie
différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles ma forêt et dévoile un peu
plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
oh
bienvenue sur arte france si vous nous
rejoignez 20h30 heure française en
france les métropoles du havrais de
charleville mézières lance donc une
campagne de dépistage massif aux comics
l'opération est menée à la poche des
fêtes de fin d'année dans l'espoir
d'améliorer la stratégie gouvernementale
tester alertés et protéger la campagne
doit durer quelques jours et va reposer
en grande partie sur les tests
antigénique et sont disponibles dans
plusieurs sites pharmacie laboratoire et
cabinets médicaux gratuitement à
destination des volontaires on a ensuite
le tour de roue b et saint-etienne au
total quatre villes françaises sont donc
concernés et une opération de dépistage
lancé à la veille du déconfinement dès
demain il y aura plus besoin d'un thé
station pour circuler mais un couvre feu
sera mis en place à partir de 20 heures
et jusqu'à 6 heures du matin retour sur
les nouvelles mesures sanitaires avec
cyrielle boe et quentin mauclair vous
aussi vous avez du mal à suivre
pas de panique à partir de ce mardi
voici les règles énoncées par le
gouvernement cette journée marque le
point de départ du déconfinement partiel
fini donc les attestations à répétition
mais à partir de 20 heures et jusqu'à 6
heures chacun chez soi
un couvre-feu qui tolèrent toutefois
quelques dérogations
parmi les exceptions du couvre-feu se
déplaçaient entre son domicile et son
travail sera toujours autorisés
même si le gouvernement persiste et
signe lorsqu'il est possible
le télétravail reste la règle
pour les fêtes de fin d'année le
gouvernement a tranché si pour le
réveillon de noël le couvre feu sera
levé pour le 31 décembre en revanche
c'est une toute autre histoire
les déplacements resteront interdits
entre 20h et 6h toutefois pour la
culture alors que les théâtres et
cinémas à espérer rouvrir ce 15 décembre
ils devront finalement patienter au
moins trois semaines supplémentaires
même sort pour les musées pas de sortie
non plus au restaurant avant le 20
janvier prochain
mais alors à quand la liberté
malheureusement il faudra encore s'armer
de patience l'exécutif maintient sa
position
l'indicateur des 5000 cas quotidiens
restent l'objectif clé pour alléger la
pression
et seulement s'il est atteint au 20
janvier les bars et restaurants
pourraient trouver et pour en parler
nous sommes avec jean paul stahl
infectiologues au chu de grenoble
alstom bonsoir jean paul stahl merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
donc dépistage massif aujourd'hui on l'a
vu au havre notamment votre réaction
tank infectiologues on est sur la bonne
piste cantons pratiquent ce genre de
campagne ça peut être utile pour notre
pays aujourd'hui
ça dépend ça dépend des mesures
d'accompagnement c'est à dire que
d'abord il faut bien savoir que les
tests de ses torts sont très fréquemment
faussement négatifs
donc on laisse passer pas mal de
personnes asymptomatiques qui sont quand
même porteuse donc ça ne réduit pas le
risque ce n'est pas un passeport un peu
un test négatif n'est pas un passeport
sécurité par contre effectivement il n'y
a pas de faux positifs
donc quand quelqu'un est dépistée
positive ça a un sens effectivement il
est porteur mais à ce moment là il
suffit pas de dire ah bah ça y est j'ai
un test positif
encore faut-il derrière proposer une
politique qui est de repérage de tous
les contacts autour de cette personne
pour justement retrouver la chaîne de
contamination et lui proposer quelque
chose à la personne en question
donc ça veut s'intégrer dans une
politique prêt beaucoup plus globale que
le simple test alors j'ai pas du tout
l'information sur la façon dont 7
organisé dans le détail waouh à
saint-etienne ou autre mais si ça ne
s'accompagne pas d'une politique de cet
ordre ça sert strictement à rien alors
justement testé alerte est protégé
depuis le temps qu'on nous en parle est
ce qu on y est enfin est ce qu'on y est
vraiment c'est une nouvelle stratégie
sanitaire sur laquelle mise
la france peut être en décalage avec
d'autres pays d'ailleurs les les tests
dans la population il existe depuis un
moment donc et la sécurité
elle s'est mobilisée avec ses employés
pour réaliser ce qu'on appelle le
contact racing c'est à dire le repérage
des cas autour des positif
donc là on augmente ainsi en augmente
l'échelle oui je très bien mais le cette
politique existe déjà nation c'est
justement ce que ont déploré le
gouvernement elle n'a pas vraiment
fonctionné à tel point qu emmanuel
maintenant macro on voulait la
contraindre il ya quelques semaines
encore on a testé mais plutôt compliqué
d'isoler n'est ce pas assez compliqué
puisque veggie moi il n'y a pas de
caractère obligatoire légende rock ou
non n'ont commis aucun délit dont il n'a
aucune raison d'être enfermés sauf si
lille
ils comprennent et il accepte t il ils
comprennent la responsabilité qui est la
leur de 2,6 au nez mais ça passe
exclusivement par ce genre de
comportement on peut difficilement faire
autre chose il ya d'autres pays qui ont
été beaucoup plus autoritaire mais je
crois pas que la majorité de la
population en france accepteraient d'y
veiller sous ces conditions alors il ya
aussi des pays comme la slovaquie ou le
premier ministre voilà à mais son échec
et il dit avoir perdu le pari de cette
campagne massive de dépistage 3,6
millions de personnes dépistées en un
week-end en slovaquie 100 millions
d'euros de dépenses et est finalement un
échec selon son propre aveu
est-ce que ça interroge finalement
est-ce qu'on fait bien de de pratique et
cela en france
ce n'est pas surprenant là encore je
connais pas le détail de ce qui s'est
passé lorsque jim est effectivement le
test pour le style et le test n'a
absolument aucun intérêt
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est qu'ils doivent avoir bien
conscience que le test c'est la
photographie du jour où on fait le test
mais le lendemain vous pouvez vous
contaminer donc si on voulait aller
jusqu'au bout des choses et au jusqu'à
l'absurde si l'on peut dire il faudrait
tester tout le monde tous les jours ce
qui reviendrait bien évidemment ne pas
de sens donc effectivement je suis pas
surpris qu en slovaquie il est il est
constaté l'échec de ceux des
stage aveugle et probablement sans avoir
derrière une politique cohérente
aujourd'hui on est à la veille donc de
l'avis d'un des confinement mais de
déconfinement mais d'un couvre feu de
20h à 6h l'infectiologue vous êtes
valide cette stratégie c'est vrai qu'il
ya beaucoup de confusion chez les
français qui ont du mal finalement voilà
voir ce qui se passe à appréhender les
règles qui changent
de semaine en semaine les règles ne
changent en fonction de ce qu'on
constate au niveau de l'épidémie
donc elles sont encore appelés à changer
donc ça il faut s'y habituer
c'est l'épidémie qui dicte et pas
l'inversé le ça c'est vraiment le point
le point essentiel le je crois que de
toute façon il était difficilement
faisable de continuer un confinement dur
par avait dans la période qui est dans
la période qui souffrent qui s'ouvre
pardon je crois que socialement et
économiquement ça aurait été un vrai
problème
maintenant si les français sont
responsables et s'il applique les
mesures qui sont préconisées on va s'en
sortir et janvier février mars se
passeront correctement si
malheureusement il y à un niveau
d'irresponsabilité ou de laisser aller
on appelle ça comme on veut
là par contre je crains énormément que
l'on janvier on soit obligé de
recombiner donc là notre attitude à tous
est en train de sauver ou d'essayer de
sauver le ce qui va se passer au début
de l'année 2000 21
pour vous donc si je comprends bien on
allait les moyens tout de même d'éviter
une troisième vague mais cela dépendra
un petit peu de de notre comportement à
ça ne dépend pas un petit peu ça dépend
totalement de notre comportement me dire
c'est pas un gouvernement qui nous
affecte c'est à une administration qui
nous affecte c'est nous qui infecte
notre voisin donc c'est notre
responsabilité et c'est exclusivement
notre responsabilité
si on fait attention si on applique les
mesures raisonnablement il y aura pas de
problème si on ne les applique pas il y
aura un problème ces irréductibles
j'en parle cette dernière question quand
on voit que les campagnes de vaccination
ont débuté aujourd'hui aux etats-unis
royaume-uni également en russie nous
patienterons en fin d'année mais de
début de d'année surtout prochaine ça
vous inspire quoi c'est plutôt bien
cette prudence qu'à choisi l'europe
oh c'est pas une question prénom c'est
une question de temps nécessaire pour
l'évaluation alors les anglais ont pris
les choses un petit peu plus tôt les
américains aussi il faut bien qu'on se
voit que les vaccins sont administrés
souffre lui des conditions d'urgence là
chez eux et ils sont pas encore dans le
dans la délivrance régulière comme
n'importe quel médicament
mais pourquoi pas c'est une c'est une
mesure d'urgence qui a été prise
nous on va suivre d'une dizaine de jours
une quinzaine de jours c'est finalement
pas très important l'agencé européenne
du médicament est en train de dévaluer
les vaccins il devrait sortir dans des
conclusions probablement dans le courant
de cette semaine
et puis ensuite il ya la logistique a
organisé qui est déjà en train d'être
organisées meilleurs délais pour pour
arriver là à vacciner les les cibles
comme on dit dans la dans le langage de
la vaccinologie
mais ce n'est qu'une affaire de jours et
le décalage de jours donc ça n'a pas de
ça n'a pas de signification particulière
merci beaucoup jean paul stahl
infectiologues au chu de grenoble alpes
d'avoir été avec mon direct sur rt
france et alors que la france comme
d'autres voisins européens choisi de
reporter l'ouverture de ces stations ski
en espagne la catalogne elle ouvre ses
pistes elle accueillera les premiers
skieurs la semaine prochaine les
précisions de listing là c'est officiel
les stations de ski peuvent ouvrir leurs
portes en catalogne cette décision a été
prise d'un commun accord et la région a
bel et bien autorisé leur ouverture
alors les stations peuvent ouvrir mais
en respectant toutes les mesures de
sécurité le port du masque est donc
obligatoire partout même sur les
téléphériques télécabine et lé siège la
distance sociale doit être respectée et
pour éviter l'afflux de visiteurs et les
longues files d'attentes à l'entrée ces
derniers doivent se procurer en amont
sur internet leurs forfaits de ski alors
l'ouverture était sur la table depuis
plusieurs semaines mais les
professionnels du secteur se montrer
très prudents alors par ailleurs la
catalogne a également annoncé
l'ouverture de ces centres commerciaux
comme vous pouvez le voir derrière moi
alors ils peuvent ouvrir à 30 % de leur
capacité d'accueil habituelle et
uniquement s'ils sont bien ventilé ça
permet d'éviter les concentrations trop
importante dans les rues commerçantes
alors malgré toutes ces annonces des
restrictions continue d'être en vigueur
en catalogne il n'est pas possible ni
d'entrée ni de sortir de la région
actuellement
mais pour les fêtes les déplacements en
dehors seront autorisés afin de pouvoir
rendre visite à ses proches et la pêche
française menacée par la crise sanitaire
elle aussi contre les confinement et la
fermeture des restaurants difficile pour
nombre de professionnels du secteur de
s'y retrouver ces dernières
s'inquiètent pour leur avenir renault
parquet et c'est le far j'avais que
cyrielle boe pour les explications il
aurait dû être immergé dans l'eau ils
sont aujourd'hui soigneusement rangés
sur le pont du bateau file et casiers ou
encore ciré tout ce matériel ne devrait
pas revoir la mer avant un moment
face au confinement et dix pêcheurs
depuis 20 ans a décidé de rester à quai
au prix du poisson c'est pas rentable de
ses pas rentable d'aller travailler au
premier compliment on a perdu 50 entre
40 et 50% de la valeur du présent là le
deuxième confinement on
il ya certaines espèces qui se
maintiennent parce qu'il n'y a pas
énormément de pêcher mais sur les
espèces qui sont le plus pêché
on peut perdre jusqu'à 60 70 % du prix
tous les beaux poissons principalement
pour la restauration du fait que c'est
fermé
on n'a pas de on vend le poisson que les
marieurs achète de bois sont quand même
très très bas prix un prix qui a chuté
de manière vertigineuse depuis l'année
dernière en 2019 le kilo de bar se
vendait 15 euros
cette année seulement 5 euros jean-marie
pêcheurs depuis 20 ans à fécamp tente de
garder un semblant d'activité
l'avenir lui semble pourtant bien
incertain pour lui les aides du
gouvernement sont insuffisantes face aux
difficultés rencontrées
voilà je ne sais pas trop sur voir
partir ou pas c'est pas facile pour nous
le gouvernement nous promet monts et
merveilles
ce qui n'est pas le cas si vous n'avez
pas de fermeture administrative
vous n'avez pas grand chose pourtant on
est soumis
l'impact du coc vide les cours est en
mauvais les restaurants fermés les ya
pas deux il ya pas de cours dans le
poisson aux conséquences de la crise
sanitaire vient s'ajouter la question du
breakbeat les acteurs du secteur sont
formels si l'interdiction de travailler
dans les eaux britanniques et mise en
vigueur la pêche française ne s'en
remettra pas et pour cause leur bateau
comme ceux de la belgique ou encore des
pays bas pourrait alors se rabattre sur
les eaux hexagonal une issue dramatique
pour les ressources maritimes déjà
menacée par la pêche intensive est la
pêche un sujet central est un point
d'achoppement entre britanniques et
européens les négociations aux breaks
sites doivent continuer tant qu'un
accord est possible déclaration de
l'allemagne qui assure jusqu'à la fin de
l'année la présidence du conseil de
l'union européenne
le point sur les derniers événements
avec grégoire douce et londres et
bruxelles joue les prolongations alors
que les échanges sur le brésil devait
initialement prendre fin ce dimanche
soir le premier ministre britannique
boris johnson et la présidente de la
commission européenne
ursula von der leyen ont finalement
décidé de les poursuivre sans indiquer
pour autant de dates butoirs une
échéance toutefois le 31 décembre qui
sonnera le glas de la période de
transition
selon des diplomates européens les
négociations auraient fait quelques
progrès ce lundi mais des blocages
persisterait en particulier sur le sujet
de la pêche
ursula von der leyen évoque une dernière
ligne droite crucial
tout d'abord il ya du mouvement
c'est bien la période de transition se
termine nous parlons d'un nouveau départ
avec de vieux amis mais nous devons
également être clair à partir du 1er
janvier
et ce dans trois semaines le royaume uni
sera un pays tiers à l'union européenne
et nous avons déjà prévu un paquet
financier dans l'accord nous sommes dans
la dernière ligne droite mais elle est
cruciale
nous voulons des règles du jeu
équitables pas seulement dès le départ
mais aussi sur le long terme
bah tu auras overtime boris johnson
accepte donc de proroger les discussions
mais garde un discours teinté de
pessimisme
la commission est très déterminé à
poursuivre
les négociations comme elles ont été
faites entre nous et la commission et
c'est très bien
je dois répéter qu'un le plus probable
maintenant il sait bien sûr que nous
devons nous préparer aux conditions de
l'om ces conditions de l'australie et
n'oubliez pas tout le monde
nous avons fait d'énormes préparatifs
pour cela nous n'avons pas fait tout ça
depuis quatre ans et demi pour rien
parmi les autre pierre d'achoppement
l'union européenne craint notamment une
concurrence déloyale de la part des
britanniques
faute d'accord ce serait alors les
règles de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce qui s'appliquerait et pour en
parler nous sommes avec l'autre
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude blanche
besson
d'être avec nous et est il inévitable
que l'autre que l'europe et le
royaume-uni aboutissent cette impasse
dans les négociations
je crois qu'on peut le soutenir parce
que en effet à partir du moment où la
structure des négociations des briques
site a été coupée en deux puisque il ya
eu d'abord la négociation cela sur la
sortie qui nous a occupés pendant trois
ans et qui a abouti il ya un an avec un
traité qui a été signé et ratifié et qui
étaient mises en oeuvre
les anglais sont sortis les britanniques
sont sortis le 1er février dernier
et puis la deuxième négociation qui les
négociations sur le régime futur l'airé
change entre le royaume uni et l'union
européenne
et là-dessus l'article 50 du traité de
lisbonne qui est l'article de sortie de
l'union européenne et est assez ambiguë
mais il permettait sans doute d'avoir
une négociation unique mais ni la grande
bretagne ni l'union européenne ne le
souhaitait la grande bretagne parce
qu'elle était pressé de sortir et
l'union européenne parce qu'elle
préférait négocier le statut du régime
extérieur avec un pays tiers et la
grande bretagne puisque depuis février
elle n'est plus à l'intérieur du système
de décision donc pour ces raisons on est
devant une situation dans laquelle boris
johnson dit mais je ne demande pas grand
chose je demande d'avoir un accès libre
à votre marché et puis et puis c'est
tout à partir du 1er janvier prochain
donc une zone de libre échange et
l'union européenne dit ça n'est pas si
simple que cela
parce que notre marché c'est 450
millions de consommateurs le marché
britannique ses 67 millions de
consommateurs donc il faut ajouter
quelque chose pour faire la balance et
ce quelque chose c'est précisément les
droits de pêche la continuation des
droits de pêche des marins des marins
européens
et puis en même temps l'union européenne
aussi est en droit de dire je veux
pouvoir vérifier que les conditions de
concurrence les conditions sociales les
conditions environnementales les
subventions d'état sont équitables et
quelles sont elles suivent le régime
européen d'origine sonne se récrie en
disant je ne veux être soumis à aucune
réglementation européenne a aucun
jugement européen a aucune comparaison
européenne à partir du 1er janvier
prochain
on a donc deux partenaires qui négocient
l'un comme l'autre sur des principes et
quand on exclut de négocier sur des
principes il ya peu de chances qu'on
aboutisse à un accord
alors pourquoi continuer les
négociations ah ben c'est très utile de
continuer les négociations pour deux
raisons la première c'est que aucun des
deux partenaires ne veut se voir
attribuer la responsabilité de la
rupture et donc de l'échec et la
deuxième c'est que comme dans cette
négociation
dans le fond on joue au poker menteur
c'est à dire qu'on fait comme si on
avait la conviction que c'est l'autre
qui finalement va céder au finish
eh bien il faut aller au finish pour
voir si en effet l'un des deux sets
quel est le premier qui craque et ça
peut arriver d'ailleurs parce qu il se
peut que pour des raisons de politique
intérieure britannique boris johnson à
un moment donné autour de noël ou un peu
avant le 31 décembre estiment qu'il a
plus d'intérêt à conclure un accord
suivant ce que lui propose union
européenne que ne pas avoir d'accord
parce que il ya effectivement un certain
nombre de domme d'affaires un certain
nombre de secteurs économiques et même
de députés aux communes qui commence à
s'agiter sérieusement à la perspective
du désordre qui va s'installer à partir
du 1er janvier
et puis du côté l'union européenne bien
sûr les états membres sont restés unis
au dernier conseil européen d'ailleurs
ils ont évité d'évoquer le sujet ils ont
simplement écouté le compte rendu de
madame ursula von der leyen
mais n'ont pas discuté le sujet parce
que ce vrai peut-être risqué de faire
apparaître de légère divergence les
pays-bas l'allemagne insiste d'ailleurs
dans leur déclaration à ce qu'on fasse
tout ce qui est possible pour aboutir à
un accord et qu'on a jusqu'au bout de la
négociation est finalement effectivement
peut-être certains états membres serait
t'il enclins à modifier le mandat de
négociations aient à faire des
concessions mais pour ça il faudra
l'unanimité et il n'y aura pas
d'unanimité pour ça d'ici le 31 décembre
alors boris johnson survivre at site où
le break 6 turbines attila boris johnson
or probablement les deux mais ça n'est
pas sûr johnson commence à avoir
quelques problèmes avec la partie
modérée des conservateurs qui trouve
qu'en effet les secousses économiques
risquent d'être extrêmement brutal en
début d'année et c'est d'ailleurs pour
probablement pour faire diversion
il a lancé une vaccination massive
contre le coc vie 19 puisque ça permet
de créer un autre sujet d'actualité
et puis comme manifestement il risque
d'être accusé en janvier du désordre qui
qui ce qui ce qui se situe aux
frontières britannique et notamment du
côté de calais et dans le kent et bien
il
il fera état de la manière dont il a
lancé les vaccinations contre le coc vie
de 19 par ailleurs évidemment à l'avoir
la deuxième partie de votre question je
répondrai que on ne peut pas exclure que
dans cinq ans dans sept ans dans dix ans
un autre gouvernement britannique avec
une composition différente de la
population britannique demande à re
devenir membre de l'union européenne ou
tout simplement à conclure un accord
d'union douanière avec l'union
européenne
dans ce cas là et bien il faudra
s'asseoir et prévoir une négociation
probablement de plusieurs années merci
claude blanchemaison d'avoir été avec
nous dans le reste
l'actualité nouvelle nuit de
manifestations à tirana la capitale de
l'albanie
des centaines de personnes ont bravé
l'interdiction de se rassembler pour
dénoncer un drame qui ne passent pas la
mort d'un jeune homme tué par la police
après avoir enfreint le couvre-feu en
vigueur à cause du coc vide 19éme illico
h pour la cinquième nuit consécutive ils
sont descendus crier leur colère après
la mort de claudiane rachat le jeune
homme a été abattu par un policier mardi
dernier pendant le couvre-feu nocturne
mises en place pour lutter contre la
pandémie
selon sa famille il était sorti pour
acheter des cigarettes
depuis ce drame malgré les mesures de
restrictions imposées par le
gouvernement
des manifestants se réunissent pour
demander justice vous tuer à nouveau nos
enfants c'est une honte pour cette
nation que des enfants subissent de tels
abus
nous n'avons tué personne vous avez tué
vous avez installé les drogues et vous
avez détruit notre pays pendant la
mobilisation alors que certains
manifestants ont lancé des projectiles
sur la police
les forces de l'ordre ont répliqué par
des tirs de grenades lacrymogènes et des
canons à eau
certains protestataires ont été arrêtés
ils m'arrêtent parce que je recherche la
liberté il n'y a pas de liberté sans
résistance j'exhorte les jeunes albanais
à s'unir à se réveiller
la nation est en danger d'autres se sont
symboliquement rendu à la police
s'allongeant sur le sol avec les mains
dans le dos les manifestants menacent de
poursuivre leur mobilisation jusqu'à
obtenir la démission du directeur
général de la police ils demandent
également une réforme de l'institution
sander les sages le ministre de
l'intérieur à lui déjà démissionné
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur la rencontre entre
eux emmanuel macron et les membres de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
alors que certains se disent déçus de
l'avancée des négociations le président
qui annonce un référendum pour inscrire
le climat dans la lutte contre le climat
dans la constitution et puis nous
parlerons du procès des attentats
le janvier 2015 trois mois et demi après
son ouverture il touche à sa fin ce
lundi avec les ultimes plaidoiries de la
défense et les derniers mots de l'accusé
verdict attendu mercredi
[Musique]
bien sûr il ya des choses qui changent
bien sûr le monde change
il a d'ailleurs changé entre l'enfance
du général de gaulle et 1969
ce qui ne change pas c'est la condition
humaine et une certaine idée de la
civilisation se fait de la dignité de la
personne humaine et de sa liberté si
vous aviez deux ou trois mots pour
caractériser ce que vous appelez la
méthode lac titude l'art de gouverner
vous diriez quoi tout d'abord
l'indépendance de la nation
ensuite la souveraineté du peuple et
enfin une conception de la france une et
indivisible
appuyez sur la fierté nationale devons
réapprendre à dire non comme disait
malraux seul l'esclave dit toujours oui
de salariés écrit au dessus du bureau de
chaque responsable politique en
particulier de ceux qui se prétendent
des hommes d'état
[Musique]
et
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
est-ce qu'on peut être défenseurs du
climat de la nature et des animaux et en
même temps aimait la chasse bien sûr
c'est avoir conscience justement des
populations de comment les gérer si
aujourd'hui on arrive à plus ou moins
trouver un équilibre entre la
l'urbanisation l'agriculture et puis les
espaces naturels c'est grâce à la chasse
grâce aux chasseurs
selon des ong la chasse et la cause de
disparition de certaines espèces j'ai
bien l'impression que les espèces sont
sont en grande partie conservée grâce à
la gestion des chasseurs aujourd'hui
vous avez 23 ans vous êtes une femme
qu'est ce que vous espérez apporter
justement à ce monde de la chasse si je
peux aider avec avec ce que je fais sur
les réseaux sociaux etc keira a montré
un autre aspect de la chasse et à donner
envie à certaines personnes de la
découvrir
ça me fait très plaisir
[Musique]
on
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous parlerons de tout sans langue de
bois
[Musique]
la chasse est un lobby
donc il pèse très lourd il faut arrêter
de dire que on a besoin des chasseurs
qu'on a besoin de régulation on n'a
jamais eu la preuve de ça cette
réduction du débat justement entre le
tout blanc a le tout noir ne nuit-elle
pas finalement à l'idée même que les
français pour espère de la chasse je
crois pas que ce soit réduire le débat
bhl de rappeler que c'est un plaisir qui
va jusqu'à la mort cc c'est ça
l'essentiel et c'est pour ça que c'est
un sujet très très épidermique parce que
s'ils une histoire de vie et de mort il
faut protéger la végétation pour
protéger la faune il faut protéger notre
santé
tout ça c y et n'oublions pas tous nos
problèmes viennent du mépris qu'on a sur
le reste du monde vivant donc il faut il
faut arrêter de laisser les chasseurs
faire leur bêtise et je suis poli
et puis
on parle de l'afrique comme d'un
continent en perpétuelle de vie son
dysfonctionnement actuel tient à
l'absence de redistribution à la
population par des dirigeants qui ont
une fâcheuse tendance à sugar d'épeautre
les pays occidentaux ont favorisé cette
dérive en encourageant le maintien au
pouvoir de politiciens de plus en plus
âgés pour assurer la stabilité des pays
et des sous régions elles ont pu la
prétention de croire que les valeurs
qu'elle défend des est imposé par la
force dans leur conquête était universel
dans cette terre des possibles
s'esquisse les figures du monde à venir
il faut changer notre logiciel et
arrêtez de dénigrer le faire à
l'africaine en octroyant au management à
l'anglo-saxonne
[Musique]
21h soyez les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france merci nous rejoindre pour cette
deuxième des missions tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi 14 décembre la convention
citoyenne pour le climat emmanuel macron
continuent d'échanger en ce moment même
avec ses membres qui insiste pour avoir
enfin des décisions fortes pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique
le chef de l'état qui vient d'annoncer
un référendum pour inscrire la lutte
conte pour le climat dans la
constitution
plus de trois mois après son ouverture
dernier jour d'audience du procès des
attentats de janvier 2015 ultimes
plaidoiries de la défense et derniers
mots des accusés avant que la cour ne se
retire pour délibérer jusqu'à mercredi
les peines de cinq ans de prison à la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité ont
été réclamées à l'encontre des 14
accusés soupçonnés d'avoir assisté les
auteurs des attaques at a abattu après
les attentats enfin du confinement et
passage au couvre-feu entre 20 heures et
6 heures du matin à partir de demain le
besoin d'attestation journée deux villes
le havre et charleville charleville
mézières donne le coup d'envoi
aujourd'hui d'une campagne de dépistage
massif aux qu'ovide restaurateurs
hôteliers ou encore gérants de
discothèques ont manifesté à paris une
veulent qu'une chose rouvrir au plus
vite
[Musique]
en côte d'ivoire alassane ouattara
invite l'opposition au dialogue en vue
des législatives déclarations du
président lors de son discours
d'investiture pour son troisième mandat
controversé une main tendue pour tenter
d'aboutir à une réconciliation nationale
après des tensions d'élections qui ont
fait 85 morts
[Musique]
emmanuel macron s'entretiendront depuis
cet après midi par visioconférence avec
un des membres de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat vous vous
souvenez ses 150 citoyens tirés au sort
qui ont rendu un rapport en juillet
dernier avec 149 propositions pour
réduire notamment les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre d'au moins 40% limite
d'ici 2030
avant même le coup d'envoi ils ont
dénoncé des ambitions revues à la baisse
monaco dès lors avec grégoire douce et
150 citoyens ont été tirés au sort pour
participer à cette convention citoyenne
pour le climat ils ont pour mission de
proposer une série de mesures qui
permettraient de réduire les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre d'au moins 40%
d'ici à 2030 par rapport à 1990 la
dernière rencontre entre les membres de
cette assemblée et le président remonte
au mois de juin à l'elysée
depuis les citoyens qui se sont penchés
sur le dossier pendant neuf mois ont
manifesté leur amertume est pointé du
doigt un manque d'ambition générale et
de soutien clair à leurs travaux dans
une tribune publiée dans le monde le
militant écologiste cyril dion appel
emmanuel macron à tenir ses engagements
la catastrophe est maintenant à nos
portes et il sera bientôt trop tard pour
éviter le pire par dessus tout nous vous
le demandons parce que nous croyons
toujours même si c'est un peu vieux jeu
que tenir sa parole pour un président de
la république c'est le socle de nos
démocraties les échanges risquent d'être
tendue puisque les propositions seraient
menacés de détricotage en effet le chef
de l'état avait déjà évoqué sa volonté
de reprendre 146 des 149 proposition de
la ccc des mesures qui devraient par la
suite être reprise dans le projet climat
présenté en 2021 aux ministres puis au
parlement
parmi elles l'interdiction de louer des
logements très mal isolé renforcer très
fortement le malus sur les véhicules
polluants ou encore taxer davantage le
carburant pour l'aviation de loisirs
depuis quelques mois
emmanuel macron envoie des signaux
plutôt négatifs concernant la ccc ce qui
a crispé particulièrement les esprits
avant l'échéance j'ai 150 citoyens
je les respecte mais je ne vais pas dire
que ce qu'il propose c'est l'habit
le coran emmanuel macron avait déjà fait
grincer des dents en septembre
concernant la demande de moratoire sur
le déploiement de la 5g
j'entends beaucoup de voix qui s'élèvent
pour nous expliquer qu'il faudrait
relever la complexité des problèmes
contemporains en revenant à la lampe à
huile
je ne crois pas que le modèle amish
permettent de régler les défis de
l'écologie contemporaine on va expliquer
débattre lever les doutes tordre le cou
à toutes les fausses idées mais oui la
france va prendre le tournant de la 5g
parce que c'est le tournant de
l'innovation
face aux critiques l'exécutif déclare
avoir été pris par la crise du coc vite
19 qui aurait concentrer tous les
efforts du gouvernement
une pandémie qui a notamment conduit
l'état français a octroyé des
milliardaires des secteurs très
polluants tels que l'automobile ou
l'aéronautique
une situation qui a contribué à reporter
et à infléchir certaines propositions de
la ccc mauvais élèves lors de la cop 21
la france et l'union européenne se sont
accordés pour réduire d'au moins 55 %
leurs émissions de co2 d'ici à 2030
le bilan écologique de paris est mauvais
reste à voir si la france sera à la
hauteur de ses engagements l'année
prochaine alors que certains membres
jugent décevant le projet de loi climat
fondée sur leurs propositions ils
attendent des décisions fortes de la
part du président emmanuel macron qui
vient d'annoncer un référendum pour
inscrire la lutte pour le climat dans la
constitution mais avec ses promesses
emmanuel macron ne se retrouve-t-il pas
pris à son propre piège place au
décryptage avec nos invités
[Musique]
mais pour en parler nous sommes avec
martine filleul sénatrice socialiste du
nord bonsoir martine filleul merci
d'être avec nous lavaud côté fendu en
bon soir florian philippot président des
patriotes bonsoir florian philippot
merci d'être avec nous on va s'arrêter
quelques instants donc sur ces premières
annonces puisque cette conférence a
toujours lieu au moment où nous parlons
l'une des plus fortes le chef de l'état
qui annonce un référendum pour inscrire
la lutte contre le climat dans la
constitution c'est est ce que vous
attendiez notamment martin fioles et
écoutez moi je pense que le référendum
c'est une arme assez spectaculaire pour
emmanuel macron ça va lui permettre
d'asseoir en quelque sorte une
légitimité environnementale qu'il
n'avait pas réussi à avoir jusqu'à
présent puisqu'il a fait des
déclarations tout à fait contradictoires
donc ça doit lui permettre en tout cas
je l'espère d'associer les français
véritablement à la transition écologique
filippo c'est une annonce forte selon
vous ce référendum qu'est-ce que ça va
changer finalement concrètement est-ce
que ça a vraiment une portée aussi
importante qu'on le présente selon vous
le référendum tel qu'il est annoncé ne
changera rien
c'est à dire qu'il ajouterait un mot
l'article premier de la constitution
et quand je vois la masse de choses de
mesures très importantes pour la vie du
pays la vie de nos compatriotes que son
gouvernement a fait passer comme ça un
peu à la sauvette sont jamais consulté
le peuple français on se dit quand même
que c'est ça tout du marketing si vous
voulez il se fait un référendum pour
essayer essayer d'obtenir un bon
résultat électoral victoire électorale
sans trop de difficultés sur quelque
chose qui sera sommes tous très
consensuel comment être contre l'ajout
d'un terme aussi consensuel dans la
constitution mais ça ne réglera rien on
aimerait investir un dom pour savoir si
on continue avec le modèle de libre
échange où est ce qu'on va vers les
circuits courts et protectionnisme ça ce
serait intéressant et ça c'est un impact
sur notre vie vraiment ou bien un
référendum sur le fric site sur est ce
qu'on continue avec cette union
européenne qui a des politiques
d'ailleurs très polluantes ou est ce que
on retrouve une indépendance nationale
pour faire autre chose ça ce serait
respecté les français que de la reposer
cette question et de respecter leur
décision mais il a préféré le choix du
du référendum marketing martine filleul
vous vous êtes d'accord avec ce
diagnostic de référendum marketing comme
nous le dit florian philippot est un peu
sévère selon vous c'est en tout cas de
la part d' emmanuel macron une manière
de sortir du piège dans lequel il
s'était placé avec cette convention
citoyenne qu'il avait créée en il avait
en même temps créé beaucoup d'espoir et
il crée de la déception par un certain
nombre de mesures qui ne vont pas
jusqu'au bout et avec ce référendum est
bien une sorte de ce piège est
effectivement en faisant valider en
quelque sorte par les français ces choix
et donc en cela je trouve que c'est
extrêmement habile de sa part
enfin mes semelles qu'une habile oui
tout à fait parce qu en quoi martin
fioles ça nous promet finalement des
actions concrètes et voilà c'est ça peut
se contenter d'être une déclaration
d'intention tout simplement voilà c'est
inscrit dans la constitution ça y est
j'ai fait ce qu'il fallait mais enfin
howell concret dans tout ça est ce que
ça nous le garantis florian philippot
ben non bien sûr que non mais vous savez
pendant que nous serons peut-être en
campagne à férin d'air je ne sais pas si
ce sera très passionnant pour les
français sur ce mot dans la discussion
l'union européenne s'ils n'y aura de
nouveaux accords de libre échange elle
veut enseigner un nouveau là c'est
l'accord mercosur on a eu des nouvelles
macro avait annoncé qu'il avait bloqué
cet accord libre échange avec les pays
d'amérique du sud dont le brésil est
bien une coalition de pays européens
plus de la commission européenne plus
l'ambassadeur de l'ue en peine au brésil
se sont réveillés pour forcer quand même
ce traité et ça c'est très polluants
parce que s'il voulait ça met des gros
cargo sur les océans
ça fait importer des jaugeurs notamment
dont on sait que c'est une des causes
de déforestation de l'amazonie de ça et
ça ça va oui ça ça avance comme en mars
dernier l'union peine est soumis à un
accord de libre échange avec le vietnam
en avril avec le mexique etc et et voilà
ça c'est concret et ça c'est polluant et
en plus ça détruit notre agriculture est
partie de notre industrie etc donc voila
moi je le regrette que la france en soir
en soit réduite comme ça avoir un
président qui fait qui fait un petit
coup politicien c'est effectivement une
habilité politicienne mais c'est avec
une habilité politicienne et
électoraliste
est ce ça devrait être jugé comme sa
part des français à l'égard de la
convention citoyenne avant cette réunion
un qui est toujours en cours je vous le
rappelle puisque les décisions nous
arrive une par une je suis d'accord sur
le chèque alimentaires notamment nous
dit emmanuel macron il faut qu'on le
fasse et donc on va le faire
en revanche report de la décision sur la
rénovation obligatoire des langes mans
un nom un manque d'ambition nous ont dit
notamment le garant de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat cyril d'ions
écouter discrètement le gouvernement est
en train de détricoter et d'affaiblir
bon nombre de leurs mesures avant de les
soumettre votre formelle des députés ou
des français sinon tous pour qu emmanuel
macron respecte sa parole et soumettent
sans filtre les propositions de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat au
référendum et au parlement donc voilà de
quoi satisfaire cyril d'ions fin juin à
l'elysée en tout cas il s'était engagé à
reprendre son filtre 146 des
propositions initiales de de la
convention je vous propose d'écouter la
réaction de l'eurodéputée écologiste
yannick jadot cette fois ci ce
quinquennat est perdue pour le climat
vous êtes un décor florian philippot les
promesses n'engagent que ceux qui les
écoutent ce quinquennat est tout
simplement perdu pour le climat oui je
suis pas certain qu'avec yannick jadot
ça aurait changé grand chose mais c'est
pas bien pas tenir sa parole sas et sata
quand il avait annoncé fin juin qu'il
reprendrait toutes les mesures sauf 3 on
savait que ce serait fou je veux dire
pourquoi on savait que ce serait faux
faut se reporter un article du caté
publié dans marianne
juillet j'invite tout le monde dit
l'aixois en ligne allez le voir il ya
énormément des propositions parfois très
intelligente qui ont été faits par cette
convention qui sont parfaitement
interdite aujourd'hui par le droit
européen même de la modulation la tva
donc des taux de tva différents selon la
distance de votre nous via votre produit
c'est interdit par une directive
européenne qui date de 2006 et qui règle
la tva donc c'est un affront il aurait
dû savoir aurait dû informer les
conventionnels comme on dit les citoyens
qui ressort que de toute façon il ne
pourrait pas le respecter
même saussure renforcer les clauses
environnementales dans les marchés
publics etc
tout ça est codifié complètement au
niveau européen il y en a plein d'autres
un salaire minimum pour les petits
pêcheurs les petits éleveurs c'est une
belle idée en inscrivant sa dans la pac
mais ça n'est pas possible par la pâques
etc
il y avait un mensonge et le départ ça a
été ça a été le non dit et non seulement
il ya des sujets qui étaient interdits
d'abord qu'il était interdit d'aborder
dans cette convention je sais puisque
chez moi j'ai eu moi même des citoyens
en téléphone qui m'ont contacté
ils m'ont dit dès qu'on allait sur le
sujet du libre-échange talent pour nous
recadrer tout eu dans dix ans ce n'est
pas le sujet ah si c'est sûr et c'est un
des grands sujets quand on parle de
d'environnement mais ça ils n'avaient
pas droit d'en parler
et deuxièmement il y avait plein de
propositions pas qu'ils ont fait à la
fin qui sont très bonnes mais qui sont
totalement impossible tant qu'on est
dans l'union européenne alors eu notre
colère est en train de monter c'est
celle-là représentant trois
représentations nationales députés et
sénateurs demandent un débat au
parlement sur l'ensemble des
propositions
vous faites partie martine filleul de
ses élus vous avez précisément signé
cette tribune qui elle va s'afficher sur
nos écrans la voici en titre vous
interpellez emmanuel macron respecter
vos engagements
c'est ce que vous dites au chef de
l'état martine filleul
expliquez-nous weeps absolument je fais
partie de ces parlementaires qui demande
au chef de l'état d'avoir un débat avec
la représentation nationale sur
l'ensemble des propositions de la
convention citoyenne car encore une fois
il a suscité beaucoup d'espoir il a
et cette convention est donc il faut
qu'il a jusqu'au bout de la démarche
jusqu'au bout dans la transparence
jusqu'au bout dans la discussion et
encore une fois le président de la
république s'est mis dans un piège et
donc maintenant il faut qu'il aille
jusqu'au bout et qu'il accepte cette
discussion
la convention a fait des propositions
tout à fait concrète et je pense qu'on
peut les mettre en place
on peut les mettre à la disposition des
français
et moi je suis prête comme sénatrice a
travaillé sur chacune de ces
propositions en lien avec les citoyens
florian philippot finalement pourquoi
elles sont aussi compliqué de mettre en
oeuvre toutes ces propositions il ya
voilà un principe de réalisme qui se
pose pour le chef de l'état est
finalement ce ne serait simple pour
personne quel que soit le parti
bon d'abord il ya il ya son idéologie
propre qui fait que sur certains sujets
il n'est pas accessible à une autre
vision des choses et ça je pense que
c'est fondamentalement macro est un
ultra libéral mondialiste et quand on
lui parle de éventuellement de
protectionnisme ou de régulation plus
forte dans un sens plus environnementale
et plus sociale ça va souvent ensemble
il entend pas parce que pour lui c'est
la loi du marché la loi du plus fort et
deuxièmement il ya ce que je vous disais
de toute façon il ya énormément de ces
propositions qui ne sont pas possibles
avec le droit européen parce que nous
sommes membres de l'union européenne il
faut avoir l'honnêteté de le dire donc
si on est conséquent sur ces sujets là
où quitte l'union européenne je crois
pas que ce soit le projet d' emmanuel
macron je le regrette amèrement et c'est
là dessus que j'aurais aimé un
référendum
çà çà çà çà je sais que ça passionnant
et le pays martin fia la fota à
l'idéologie des manuels micron et ce
sera le mot de la fin pour vous et une
question de courage politique et une
question d'ambition aujourd'hui emmanuel
macron n'est pas à la hauteur de
l'héritage de la coop 21 au moment où 27
pays d
id de relever l'objectif de la réduction
de gaz à effet de serre de 40 à 55 %
on se dit que décidément il n'est pas il
n'est pas à la hauteur pour la france
puisque ce n'est pas une question
européenne que de reprendre
l'utilisation des néonicotinoïdes par
exemple ou du cliff hosatte c'était bien
une question française en l'occurrence
merci en tout cas oui monsieur philippot
florian philippot le mot de la fin
oui non mais justement sur le moi
j'avais dit dès le départ sur le
glyphosate que macro ne le ferai pas je
l'avais dit il ya trois ans parce que
justement il y aurait cette pression
européenne
il ya énormément de choses qui sont
gérés au niveau européen y compris sur
les [ __ ] et néonicotinoïdes et sur les
sur les pesticides etc
donc non là aussi vous savez on est
pieds et poings liés et persister fini
il a dit qu'il leur qui le ferait un bon
lot glyphosate ans on verra celui ci
l'avenir vous donne raison merci en tout
cas martine filleul florian philippot
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france plus de trois mois après son
ouverture dernier jour d'audience du
procès des attentats de janvier 2015
ultimes plaidoiries de la défense et
derniers mots des accusés avant que la
cour ne se retire pour délibérer jusqu'à
mercredi
notre reporter katia technique suit les
échanges depuis la cour d'assises
spéciale de paris le procès des
attentats de janvier 2015 touche à sa
fin nous avons entendu les deux
dernières plaidoiries de la défense
aujourd'hui et les mots des accusés
trois mois de procès extrêmement dense
et lourd avec des témoignages engagé
courageux à la barre des plaidoiries
vibrante tant du côté de la défense que
des parties civiles évidemment
énormément de peine de douleur je
propose d'écouter à ce sujet a ni leur
saada soeur d'une des victimes de
l'hyper cacher si ni preuves
c'est très longes imaginez pas que ce
soit ou sinon parce que c'était plus
longue que prévu j'imaginais pas que ce
soit aussi fatiguant j'attends de la
cour qu'elle arrive à déterminer
précisément à évaluer précisément
ou plus précisément possible l'un la
responsabilité de chacun des accusés et
leur degré d'implication dans les actes
qui ont été commis
face à cette douleur le dernier mot des
accusés a souvent été réservée à la
compassion pour les victimes mais
quasiment tous se sont défendus d'avoir
été au courant des intentions dames et
10 coulibaly je ne suis pas un
terroriste
ont-ils crié parfois j'ai peur que ce
soit le politique qui l'emportent à dire
un des accusés side makhlouf
c'est aussi ce que déplorent les avocats
de la défense qui estime que le dossier
est truffé de zones d'ombré qu'il n'y a
pas de preuve éclatante de la
culpabilité des clients et que la
justice se doit d'être exemplaire mais
que la pression va peut-être influer sur
la lourdeur des peines vous pour vous
écouter isabelle coutant-peyre l'avocate
du principal accusé
tout le monde se rend compte de ce que
j'ai dit au début de ce procès s'avère
la réalité c'est pas seulement des
arguments de défense
c'est à dire les bons les responsables
ceux qui devraient être jugées sont pas
dans les boxes et c'est pas des
arguments de défense
je pense qu'on a c'est une affaire
d'état c'est une affaire d'état
l'état un idm présenter à l'opinion
publique des hommes de paille des hommes
de paille mais qui sont pour rien dans
ce qui s'est passé c'est parfaitement
clair ils ne sont pour rien dans ce qui
s'est passé du côté des avocats des
parties civiles on se défend de tout
désir de vengeance
il faut selon retrouver des peines juste
qui correspondent à l'implication de
chacun des accusés
je vous propose d'écouter laurence et
schumann avocate des parties civiles
il ya des accusés pour qui je pensais
que l'implication était moindre et au
cours des débats en exploitant le
dossier où les pièces on s'est aperçu
que finalement il était peut-être un peu
plus impliqué ou un peu plus dans la
connaissance du proche du projet
terroriste ou un peu plus en proximité
avec les auteurs des attentats
et puis d'autres qu'on voyait un petit
peu comme des gros ballons de baudruche
et bien finalement leur implication
c'est un petit peu réduite un petit peu
baissé par rapport aux explications
qu'ils ont pu donner mais aussi à la
présentation que l'accusation avait pu
en faire le verdict sera prononcé
mercredi à 16 heures je rappelle que les
peines requises vont de cinq ans à la
perpétuité
et pour en parler nous sommes avec samia
maktouf avocate de familles de victimes
bonsoir s'allier avec tout merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france ça y
est on y est trois mois et demi après
son ouverture le procès touche à sa fin
quel bilan peut-on en faire avant le
délibéré dans quel état d'esprit êtes
vous écoutez d'abord comme ça a été
rappelé par l'ensemble des partis
c'était un procès éprouvant lent mais il
a eu le mérite de se tenir c'est
extrêmement important que ce procès
qualifient d'historique et pu se tenir
il a pu se tenir dans le respect de
notre homme état de droit dont le
respect des droits des accusés la cour
vous l'avez rappelé il s'agit d'une cour
constituée de magistrats professionnels
elle a permis à l'ensemble des accusés
de se prononcer 2 il y a eu un débat
ouvert un débat qui a permis à
l'ensemble des accusés de d'exposer leur
point de vue il ya eu un débat clair
utile de steam pour la vérité et il y a
aussi eu ces interruptions qui témoigne
du respect scrupuleux de l'état du droit
et de du procès équitable puisque ces
suspensions correspondait justement à un
état de fatigue et de maladie d'un des
accusés
et c'était un moment fort de ce procès
où les parties civiles se sont jointes à
la aux avocats de la défense pour dire
nous refusons que l'accusé malade en
plus qu'il risque la perpétuité
la halle à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité puissent être présents à la
salle d'audience pour entendre les
plaidoiries de de la partie civile
d'entendre le réquisitoire et de pouvoir
s'expliquer s'exprimer puisque la parole
appartient en dernier à l'accusé on
voulait pour respecter les normes du
procès équitable que cette dernière
parole soit éclairé par tout ce qu'il
aura entendu non pas à travers une
visioconférence comme le décret dernière
minute avaient été pendus pour que
cette cour poursuivre ses activités et
sont les débats eh bien nous sommes nous
avons été satisfaits du fait que la
visioconférence a été écarté par le
conseil d'état et cela est un
soulagement parce que ça consacre une
fois de plus le principe du procès
équitable et du respect deux des accusés
qui étaient là pour une manifestation
ultime de la vérité 2pour en présence
des victimes d'ailleurs samia maktouf
évidemment c'est ce qu'espèrent tous les
proches des des victimes avoir des
débuts de réponse est ce que vous avez
le sentiment sur ce point là qu'il y a
une forme de de soulagement on va dire
de début de réponse à l'impensable
finalement à l'inexplicable pour
certainement écouté je ne pourrais pas
m'aventurer à vous dire qu'il y a eu des
réponses
tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
ce procès a eu le mérite de se tenir
les victimes étaient là parce qu'elle
voulait entendre elle voulait voir elle
voulait des réponses
malheureusement des zones d'ombré
demeurent il faut reconnaître que il ya
des angles morts il faut reconnaître
qu'il y a des
des questions qui sont restées sans
réponse que malheureusement le procès
n'éclairera pas les victimes sur toutes
les circonstances de ce procès en
revanche ce procès s'est tenu ce procès
a eu lieu il y a eu un débat constructif
il a eu un délit a eu un débat qui a
permis aux victimes de suivre les
éléments et les explications de ces
accusés parce que c'est aussi ça un
procès équitable
donc oui même si le tout les un certain
nombre de questions demeurent en suspens
mais pour autant ce procès s'est tenu
pardonnez moi de le répéter c'est très
important que ce procès ait eu lieu
merci beaucoup m samia maktouf avocate
de familles de victimes d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons des restaurateurs des
hôteliers ou des gérants de discothèques
ils ont manifesté à paris pour alerter
le gouvernement et ne veulent qu'une
chose rouvrir au plus vite et ce n'est
pas gagné pour eux malheureusement puis
direction la côte d'ivoire où alassane
ouattara revit de l'opposition au
dialogue en vue des législatives
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la veille d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent là l on
soit vient de grignan aujourd'hui une
gauche extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande île interview ya pas une
façon plus pauvres de défendre un
système que de dire qu'il est moins pire
qu'un autre la table c'était une volonté
collectés vous le savez pour moi que dès
qu'on dit il n'y a pas d'alternative on
sort du pays il est clair que tout le
monde attend sable est-ce que c'est
grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des soul unis vers une forme quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était les gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas d'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté vous
remercie d'avoir un métier
[Musique]
quelle image il laisse de lui diego
maradona en argentine il laisse une
image d'un d'une icône absolue d'un dieu
vivant parce qu'il a porté très haut les
couleurs d'un pays qui était humiliée
par la guerre des malouines ce pays a
gagné la coupe du monde bien alors c'est
pas une victoire militaire mais c'est
une revanche politique et sportif sur
une défaite militaire parce que la
politique et le sport font finalement
bon ménage
maradona revendiquait de mélanger sport
et politique y c'était un homme dutra
gauche on connaît sa proximité avec
castro on connaît sa proximité avec hugo
chavez
il avait cette sensibilité de toujours
incarné bien les dix khamis à dos les
sans-chemise il a toujours joué dans des
clubs qui incarnait la révolte par
rapport au pouvoir central vous êtes en
pas en train de dire finalement diego
maradona c'est l'homme du passé ce cap a
un côté paradoxal le moins que l'on
puisse dire c'est que le personnage
n'est pas lisse et qui est multiple
aspérités et c'est pour ça que c'est un
personnage de légende
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins
dulong vieux cash nous parlerons de tout
sans langue de bois
[Musique]
merci nous rejoindre en direct sur rt
france 21h30 heure française les crises
du coronavirus en français les derniers
chiffres santé publique france dénombre
3063 cas de kovy détecté en 24 heures en
baisse par rapport au lundi des semaines
précédentes le nombre de patients en
réanimation et de 2008 196 dont 210
entrer ces dernières 24 heures 372
personnes sont décédées à l'hôpital
ils ont décidé eux de manifester pour
crier leur colère les gérants de
restaurants cafés brasseries traiteur
hôtels et discothèques mais aussi des
établissements de nuit bowling et
thalasso étaient dans la rue aujourd'hui
des professionnels rassemblés à paris
sur l'esplanade des invalides
ils se sont sacrifiés réclament la
réouverture de leur établissement et
côté on s'inquiète pour l'avenir nos
entreprises surtout en territoires
ruraux
parce qu'en territoires ruraux ont alors
fait partie de l'aménagement du
territoire dans une petite commune il ya
un café un hôtel un restaurant
discothèque
malheureusement ils sont fermées en ce
moment ils ont environ peut-être plus
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont des petites
marges
et si on les aime pas on ne laisse pas
travailler ils vont fermer et après ces
contribuables qui vont payer pour ouvrir
des établissements en milieu rural prend
demande aujourd'hui on a quelques
problèmes l'état le pouvoir a fait son
travail aujourd'hui à les assurances en
un problème avec l'assurance en un
problème avec les loyers que les
propriétés retint propriétaires certains
ne jouent pas le jeu
mais aujourd'hui on a des points et puis
on a pas d'ouverture n'a pas d'objectif
d'ouverture on sait pas quand on va
réouvrir il suffit qu au mois de janvier
les gens rentrent avec un taux de
contamination élevé dans les parties
mois de février voire mars
donc aujourd'hui nous y avait une
inquiétude grandissante et j'ai peur que
de 30 % de la profession disparaissent
aux oubliettes et soit ne rouvre pas
leurs affaires au moment de l'ouverture
on paye les mêmes impôts que tout le
monde le problème c'est que nous on n'a
pas droit au chômage partiel on n'a pas
le droit aux 1500 euros d des
auto-entrepreneurs et on n'a pas droit
l'année blanche des intermittents du
spectacle donc en fait on n'est dans
aucune case
et malheureusement la seule solution
qu'on nous a proposé au bout de neuf
mois de lutte c'est 900 euros pendant
quatre mois jusqu'à février pour sous
certaines conditions et pour certaines
personnes donc c'est juste un scandale
l'aïe avait personne derrière moi qu'on
vend de leur maison ont rendu leur
appart coup tout arrêter et qui savent
plus quoi faire qui sont tout simplement
des pressions et l'air est verte sûrs de
leur établissement était prévue le 20
janvier mais elle est loin d'être
acquise en croire en tout cas le
ministre de l'économie il s'est exprimé
ce matin chez nos confrères de france
info écoute je ne peux pas vous dire
avec certitude que nous rouvrirons les
bars et les restaurants le 20 janvier ce
serait malhonnête de ma part je crois
avoir tenu un discours de vérité depuis
le premier jour de cette crise je
continuerai à le tenir
nous allons continuer à les accompagner
mais vous dira le 20 janvier c'est fini
on rouvre ce serait prendre un risque
excessif et pour en parler nous sommes
avec olivier marais et au patron du
bistrot chez mézigue dans le 19e
arrondissement de paris bonsoir olivier
mars et au conte vous écoutez bruno le
maire ce matin qui nous dit bah voilà
finalement le 20 janvier c'est pas
acquis non plus quelle est votre
réaction
commencer un petit peu avoir l'habitude
le problème c'est que systématique on a
des annonces qu'on essaye de ce qu'elle
est issue et où un discours là qu'on est
quasiment tout sûr que effectivement
sera pas là le 20 janvier donc donc
c'est assez compliqué on a on nous
demande de financer ça en plus avec avec
de la tête
donc aujourd'hui on a des affaires qui
s'endettent et le jeu on va rouvrir on
va voir un volant de dette qui va être
qui est qui risque de propulser pas mal
de daffé l'air vers leur faillite dirais
donc on est ça devient très très
compliqué et votre demande d'ailleurs a
été rejetée au conseil
d'état c'est peut-être ça le pire cette
espèce de manque de soutien tout est
dirigé selon vous on l'entendait chez
vos collègues contre notamment un les
restaurateurs mais aussi les
discothèques ça on n'en parle même plus
parce que c'est vrai que ça fait un
certain temps qu'ils sont plus là voilà
ça ça charme
oui et puis surtout enfin vous savez
nous on est un moment on comprend pas
donc on n'est pas on n'est pas amis de
ça nous avait demandé dans un premier
temps de mettre en place un protocole
sanitaire ce qu'on a fait il faut il
faut considérer quand même que moi je
travaille 70 heures comme en affaires
est ouverte par semaine dans mon
business minimum 1 g personnes dans le
monde à faire caca ulcos vides ont tous
les verts on débarrasse on fait tout
donc on est on est au coeur de l'enfer
si on considère que l'enfer c'était nos
jeux vous à faire aujourd'hui on est
fermé les chiffres continuent à monter
un moment on se dit on n'est pas un
petit peu l'espèce de deux modules de
d'action du gouvernement à ont fait
quelque chose on ferme et on ferme et on
faire des affaires donc c'est donc oui
c'est qu'on veut c'est très compliqué on
commence à en avoir un petit peu un
petit peu marre un petit peu plus qu'un
petit peu d'ailleurs alors demain les
choses changent encore il ya plus de
confinement au sens strict mais il ya un
couvre-feu ne nous réjouissons pas trop
vite 20 heures 6 heures du matin ça va
encore aggraver le cadet de la
restauration qui perd finalement la
vente à emporter cette fois ci tu sais
bien c'est moi je moi moi je suis fermé
mais j'étais j'ai des copains qu'on
contenteront tenter le truc qui devait
pas de vente à emporter l'avant et c'est
pas rentable mais juste pour continuer à
créer un lien bien partir de demain ils
vont être ouvert de 12h à 15h et c'est
en fait non c'est pas rentable on perd
de l'argent ou perd de l'argent toujours
ça nous oblige à faire des de
l'équilibrisme et c'est terrible
vraiment terrible vraiment terrible le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous a
retiré 100 % de nos recettes et on nous
couvrent pas 100% de ce qu'on a à payer
donc je connais pas une personne
aujourd'hui qui si on lui disait sur son
salaire
tiens regarde tu te retires 100% que ton
salaire par contre je t'en rendes 75% et
je te dis que je t'aide qui dirait pas à
son interlocuteur mais là tu me prend
pour un con c'est un peu le sentiment
qu'on a aujourd'hui
alors 20 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires dans le projet de budget
pour 2021
un premier pas quand même pour vous en
faites vous faites le gouvernement noah
un petit peu tout on parle du chômage
partiel mais si aujourd'hui on n'avait
pas le choix marge passée a été pris en
charge par l'état
l'état continuera à payer parce que tous
nos employés seraient au chômage tout
court
ils nous disent aujourd'hui vous allez
on doit prendre finalement ils font un
pas et on va prendre finalement les
congés payés sur les veaux mois de
fermeture simplement pareil au lieu de
nous et prendre simplement ils nous
mettent en porte à faux avec nos
employés puisque nous employer pour être
obligé de prendre des jours de repos par
anticipation c'est à dire qu'on est
obligé de mondial aux anneaux employés
aujourd'hui vous devez contribuer au
maintien de la vie de votre entreprise
mais les pauvres n'y sont pour rien
comme nous on n'y est pour rien et en
plus dans nos métiers on a beaucoup de
gens qui cumulent un petit peu les repos
parce que l'is et l'ivi ils partent
après à moi deux mois à l'étranger
de là où ils viennent pour profiter de
leur famille et c'est parce qu'ils ont
des vies clique sont quand même pas très
simple et nous aujourd'hui en train de
leur demander de prendre par
anticipation des congés pour rester ici
juste pour sauver notre entreprise
parce que l'état ne peut pas l'assumer
lui même et ça devient très compliqué
dans le discours même clairement olivier
marais tôt aujourd'hui qu'est ce que
vous demandez aujourd'hui il ya eu des
manifestations
concrètement que demandez-vous la
réouverture
autre aide mais si on n'a pas la
réouverture on n'est pas mais ça on peut
anticiper
nous on a l'impression qu'on n'est pas
plus dangereux que le métro que les
grands magasins que les grandes surfaces
même bien moins parce qu'on met des
protocoles qu'on applique et on n'a pas
ces espèces de de flou dans les galeries
commerciales etc
mais à partir du moment où ils ne le
font pas retirer nos 100 % de nos
revenus mais assumé 100% de nos dépenses
voilà et on parle même pas des revenus
de nous les patrons qui sommes pour la
plupart pas salariés très clairement
donc c'est juste nous on nous demande de
faire des efforts nous demande de payer
1 pour la politique du gouvernement
encore une fois c'est pas à nous de
payer et aujourd'hui on nous demande
même plus que ça on nous demande de nous
endetter pour survivre aujourd'hui
clairement vous estimer à combien le
nord je sais que vous n'êtes pas
économique c'est difficile c'est
peut-être une question piège mais enfin
vous parlez j'imaginais que votre
collègue vous estimer à combien le
nombre de restaurants de restaurateurs
qui vont disparaître aujourd'hui en
france ou au moins dans la capitale ne
sais pas il y en a qui disent un tiers y
en ait 30% 40%
mais vous savez on a une heure on a
cette faculté aussi à vouloir survivre
donc on va seront va se battre on va
s'endetter et puis après on va le tampon
qui va être fait ça va être ça va être
nous de nos revenus
ça va être ça va être ça va être tout ça
mais je pense qu'il va y avoir au moins
30% voix qui vous autorise de dépasser
et c'est c'est terrible merci en tout
cas olivier marais tout d'avoir été avec
nos patrons du bistrot chez
musique dans le 19e arrondissement merci
à vous en côte d'ivoire à présent
alassane ouattara a été investi ce lundi
pour un troisième mandat de président
une réduction qui avait été précédée par
de nombreuses violences
la place accordée au dialogue avec
l'opposition constitue désormais un défi
majeur pour le chef de l'état ivoirien
les détails avec robin pu l alassane
ouattara débute officiellement un
troisième mandat controversée le
président ivoirien a prêté serment ce
lundi dans un contexte politique
difficile
le scrutin présidentiel s'était déroulée
dans un climat de tension
le bilan des violences liées à la
campagne électorale s'élève à 85 morts
et près de 500 blessés le 3 novembre
peu après la proclamation officielle de
la victoire de ouattara les forces de
l'ordre avaient placé sous blocus
les résidences des leaders de
l'opposition la situation s'est
légèrement apaisées après une rencontre
le 11 novembre entre le président et
henri konan-bédié son principal rival
alassane ouattara souhaite à présent la
mise en place d'un dialogue
j'ai instruit de reprendre les
discussions avec les partis politiques
les recommandations relatives à la
commission électorale indépendante
la perspective de la tenue des élections
législatives dans le courant du premier
trimestre 2011 21
j'invite donc l'ensemble des partis
politiques à saisir cette nouvelle
opportunité qui s'offre à tous pour
aboutir à la décrispation du climat
politique
l'opposition conteste toujours la
légitimité d'alassane ouattara avant
même l'annoncé des résultats officiels
elle avait créé au conseil national de
transition afin de former un
gouvernement pour remplacer celui du
président la semaine dernière les
opposants ont fait un pas en arrière
henri konon bédié a annoncé la fin de
l'organe de transition et la nécessité
d'ouvrir des négociations
je propose dès maintenant et urgemment
en accord avec tout le poids
mission l'organisation d'un dialogue
national ce nouveau cadre de dialogue
qui verra la participation de toutes les
forces vives de la nation remplace
évidemment le cnt que l'opposition
ivoirienne avait initialement proposé un
dialogue en cours team il se met donc en
place en côte d'ivoire avec pour
objectif la tenue d'élections
législatives prévues en mars prochain et
pour en parler nous sommes avec
guillaume blot ancien conseiller aux
affaires politiques aux nations unies
bonsoir guillaume naud merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur where they france
lors de son investiture alassane
ouattara donc appelé ses opposants au
dialogue en vue des élections
législatives
est ce une main tendue par le président
réélu
oui bonjour moi même c'est bien
évidemment cela va dans le bon sens un
je pense c'est surtout que cela répond
aussi à la à la demande de l'opposition
elle-même henri konan-bédié dans son
dernier message demander ou a su tout
remplacer le cnt le conseil national
bahreïn dialogue il a appelé à un
dialogue
donc je pense aussi que cela pendant le
bon sens alors l'opposition elle
continue en tout cas de de contester le
résultat du scrutin présidentiel
on a du mal à imaginer le futur
politique dans ce contexte
oui c'était un contexte difficile dans
la mesure où dans son appel ou dans les
propositions qu'il a dernièrement fait
le président bédié il a demandé une rue
une nouvelle organisation des élections
il ne reconnaissait pas la légitimité du
président alassane ouattara
aujourd'hui je pense que cela va être
très très difficile dans la mesure où
comme vous le savez il vient de prêter
serment
cela est aujourd'hui t il va falloir
entrer aujourd'hui d'anciens le fond du
débat c'est à dire vers un dialogue
comme ils l'appellent tous d'ailleurs
inclusif un dialogue politique fort et
pour cela il ya des préalables qui sont
posées
à l'opposition quelles sont ces
préalables pour nos téléspectateurs
qu'il ignorait notamment la libération
immédiate et sans condition de tous les
opposants à reste à arrêter aujourd'hui
écroués comme pascal affi n'guessan le
bras droit de monsieur henri konan-bédié
kakou guikahue et bien d'autres je pense
à d'autres députés déjà encastré comme
alain lobognon auch de guillaume soro
est aussi le retour des exilés
politiques pensent à au président
laurent gbagbo guillaume soro dégoûter
tout le monde des exigences qui vont
être satisfaites selon vous selon ma
lecture que ce dialogue est un
aboutissement meilleur où qu'ils aillent
dans le bon sens
le président ouattara devrait
aujourd'hui faire la job ouverture sinon
beaucoup fait preuve de beaucoup de
souplesse vis-à-vis de ses opposants
mais aussi et surtout c'est qu'il faudra
comprendre
est ce que cette opposition sera t elle
capable de faire bloc unique pour faire
plier le président ouattara a ses
exigences
là aussi c'est une nouvelle question qui
se pose si tel est le cas
bien évidemment je pense que le 8 le
président ouattara devra se plier à ces
exécutions sinon il boit orienter les
débats comme il le sent il ya même un
mystère de la réconciliation qui va être
créé un promesse du président réélu
effet d'annonce selon vous où cela va
vraiment faire avancer les choses dans
le sens de la réconciliation lui parle
d'un ministère de réconciliation
l'opposition parle de la remise en route
ou en place de la cdvr c'est à dire
qu'ils avaient été ce mécanisme qui
avait été mis en place et dirigé par
l'ancien premier ministre charles konan
banny
alors est ce qu'on parle de la même
chose là aussi il faut il faut accorder
les violons ya aussi un autre grand
point qui est important c'est tout de
suite
il faudrait qu'ils envoient un message
fort à son opposition bien évidemment il
ya ces arrestations y compris notre
candidat à la présidence affi n'guessan
il ya des députés qui sont incarcérés
il faudrait le président ouattara
devrait automatiquement dès le 2 mai
matin envoyer un message fort à
l'opposition pour justement que cette
annonce de ce ministère à la
réconciliation ne soit pas comme vous le
dites
un effet d'annonce dernière question
alassane ouattara a déclaré que la côte
d'ivoire avait choisi la démocratie en
c'est vrai qu'il a été élu à 94% des
voix au premier tour
vous êtes d'accord avec ce diagnostic on
peut vraiment parler clairement d'une
élection démocratique selon vous moi je
vous dirai ceci rincon qu'observateur de
la vie politique ouest africaine et on a
eu cette grande période des coups de
force militaire et aujourd'hui on est
repassé de france militaire allait coup
de force institutionnel ce mot un coup
ko et a pris toute la région
il ya des mécanismes ce soit en change à
la veille des élections les règles du
jeu donc la constitution
donc on passe en force par un mécanisme
les juges sont à la solde du tenant du
pouvoir
et là le la ceni donc cet organe qui est
chargée est indépendante pour organiser
de nouvelles élections pareil donc aussi
là je dirais qu'il faut aujourd'hui au
revoir la question de la démocratie dans
toute la sous région
on est un exemple le cas de la guinée
qui ressemble
trait pour trait à celui la côte
d'ivoire monsieur ouattara disait t-il
que il a dû être obligé contraint de
revenir sur sa décision
parce que son défunt de désigner et et
était décédé mais là n'est pas une
raison valable pour remettre en question
d'une constitution
c'est là aussi fait débat pour vous
faire remarquer dans la vie politique
française est même le premier secrétaire
du parti socialiste
olivier faur en a appelé il a dit que la
candidature de monsieur ouattara était
anticonstitutionnelle donc la question
de la démocratie
elle ne touche pas seulement la côte
d'ivoire mais touche bon nombre de pays
ouest africain que je dirais africain et
là encore une fois il faut respecter les
règles qui sont données et tant qu'on ne
les respectent pas la démocratie ne sera
pas respectée c'est beaucoup
guillaume blot ancien conseiller aux
affaires politiques aux nations unies
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france pour évoquer cette élection en
côte d'ivoire en guinée est présent à
l'investiture d'alpha condé pour un
troisième mandat est prévue ce matin à
conakry le président guinéen a été réélu
le 18 octobre dernier
dès le premier tour avec +2 59% des
suffrages depuis deux pays a connu
plusieurs morts dans des violences post
électorales ont fait le point avec jordi
de maurice une trentaine de délégations
sont attendues à la cérémonie
d'investiture d'alpha condé prévue ce
mardi si de nombreux dirigeants du
continent ont confirmé leur présence
d'autres brillent par leur absence
c'est le cas notamment de macky sall
président du sénégal ou encore de
mouhamadou buhary chef de l'état
nigérian
la france avec qui les relations ne sont
pas au beau fixe sera représentée par
jean baptiste lemoyne secrétaire d'état
auprès de jean yves le drian ministre
des affaires étrangères conakry se
prépare pour l'événement qui aura lieu
au palais mohammed-v alors que des
mobilisations de soutien auront lieu
dans la capitale
il a été décidé de retenir deux sites de
mobilisation et d'animation le premier
c'est à l'aéroport pour dire bienvenue à
nos invités le deuxième site le plus
important c'est ici au siège national du
grand parti
rpg arc en ciel nous demandons que tout
le monde soit là pour faire la fête et
suivre en direct la fête sera belle et
ça va marquer le début de la quatrième
république
cette cérémonie d'investiture est placée
sous haute surveillance par les
autorités guinéennes
l'opposition entend manifester dans la
capitale pour exprimer sa désapprobation
à un troisième mandat d'alpha condé
cellou dalein diallo deuxième de
l'élection présidentielle avec 33% des
voix se dit prêt à manifester avec ses
alliés l'union des forces républicaines
membres du front national pour la
défense de la constitution et hésite
encore quant à sa participation
nous sommes là et nous continuons le
combat les forces de sécurité ont
interdit toute manifestation mais cela
ne nous concerne pas nous suivons les
ordres de notre leader ce qu'il va nous
dire c'est ce que nous allons faire pour
le moment nous sommes à l'écouté
d'ici là à restons vigilants et
continuons notre travail de formation
politique la guinée est secoué depuis
plus d'un an par des manifestations anti
condé un mouvement de contestation
réprimé avec force par les autorités qui
auraient fait plus de 90 morts avant le
scrutin présidentiel selon le front
national pour la défense de la
constitution
un bilan démenti par le gouvernement
guinéen dans l'actualité le cessez le
feu est il menacé dans le haut-karabagh
malgré l'accord signé en novembre sous
l'égide de la russie des manquements ont
été constatés à moscou les
correspondances d antoine frérot
après ces affrontements dans le haut
karabakh à l'azerbaïdjan fait état de
quatre morts et l'arménie de six blessés
comme on pouvait s'y attendre les deux
camps avance des informations
contradictoires concernant le contexte
de ces escarmouches bakou prétend que
les accrochages ont eu lieu sur un
territoire passé sous contrôle
azerbaïdjanais dans le cadre de l'accord
du 9 novembre tandis que yerevan déclare
avoir repoussé des tentatives
d'intrusion dans une zone censée rester
aux mains des forces qui contrôle le
haut karabagh le premier ministre
arménien a ajouté ce matin que les
offensives azerbaïdjanaise ont également
pris pour cible les soldats de la paix
russes et aux côtés de moscou
même sur la pris acte de cette violation
du cessez-le-feu
on joue la carte de l'apaisement nous
disposons de très peu
information et nous suivons
effectivement la situation c'est une
charge de travail supplémentaire pour
nos forces de maintien de la paix tous
les contacts ont été pris de manière
appropriée
voici toute l'information que nous
pouvons fournir on a eu en effet une
situation inquiétante à laquelle il a
été mis fin rapidement
on l'a entendu la russie cherche avant
tout à calmer le jeu et parvenir à une
stabilisation de la situation sur place
c'est en effet une étape indispensable à
la poursuite des négociations sur
l'avenir de ce territoire contesté
en attendant les arméniens continue de
panser leurs plaies et pleurer leurs
morts
un deuil national de trois jours a été
annoncée à partir du 19 décembre en
hommage aux personnes tombées lors de ce
conflit du haut karabagh et c'est la fin
de cette émission on se retrouve dans
quelques instants pour un point complet
sur l'actualité
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on peut être défenseurs du
climat de la nature et des animaux et en
même temps aimait la chasse bien sûr
c'est avoir conscience justement des
populations de comment les gérer si
aujourd'hui on arrive à plus ou moins
trouver un équilibre entre la
l'urbanisation l'agriculture et puis les
espaces naturels c'est grâce à la chasse
grâce aux chasseurs
selon des ong la chasse est la cause de
disparition de certaines espèces j'ai
bien l'impression que les espèces sont
en grande partie conservée grâce à la
gestion des chasseurs aujourd'hui vous
avez vingt trois ans vous êtes une femme
qu'est ce que vous espérez apporter
justement à ce monde de la chasse si je
peux aider avec avec ce que je fais sur
les réseaux sociaux expira a montré un
autre aspect de la chasse et à donner
envie à certaines personnes de la
découvrir
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde je suis pour
un appartement on est énervé grenelle
sens